today we're going to be doing color
change reaction and it's going to
involve solids going into liquids all
getting mixed together and by the
addition of a dye we'll be able to see
the reaction changing color so this
reaction actually as a name it's called
traffic lights actually do this at local
primary schools when I go out and visit
them and show them this reaction and
hopefully you'll be as wild with this as
the kids are
so what we've got here is some hot water
and cold water that's it that's all
we've got in there at the moment and
we're going to add glucose a type of
sugar into this one and sodium hydroxide
is going into this so we give that a
stir you can see there it clouds up and
you've got all the sugar dissolving in
the water that's going to need a stir as
well so you've got larger particles of
sodium hydroxide this time and the
water's cold so it's going to take
longer for it to actually dissolve in
the water okay so we've got our sodium
hydroxide we've got our glucose solution
both solutions are colorless they're
clear quite dull so with the addition of
this dye we'll be able to see a color
change reaction and if you look at in
this container it's a very it's really
dark it almost looks black but once we
add it to this you'll actually see what
color it is so in it goes you can see a
really nice swirling effect okay we're
going to make sure it's fully dissolved
in the glucose solution so really want
to make sure that indigo car mean the
glucose and the water are all mixed
together so we've got our blue solution
here we've got our colorless solution in
here we'll combine the two and you can
watch what happens so first of all it
starts out blue we pour this in and it
instantly goes green so you've got a
nice green color which won't stick
around for long once it goes green it's
happy like that but then it enters a
transitional state of red so you've got
this red color here and then finally it
goes to a nice orange then following
that will be an Amber and we'll leave it
to go to completion and its final color
change will be to yellow yeah actually
split if you can actually see something
isn't dissolved and you can see where
the colors coming up from the bottom
that's really cool okay see this is
actually a reversible reaction so what
we need to do is alright all the
component ingredients are already
suspended in water what we need to add
to this is oxygen from the air so we can
tip this into here
you can see what happens yellow in my
hand and as it goes in it's red and the
reason why it's doing that actually you
can see the bubbles there have a slight
green tinge just because we're adding
oxygen into the mix well Neil's had a
very good idea wretchedly so given that
we need oxygen to turn this reaction
around he's got up just so happens he
has a cylinder of pure oxygen next to us
so we're going to bubble some of this
into that and see what happens okay
let's see what happens all excellent
it's really nice doing it this way
because rather than the whole mixture
being shaken up in one go you can see
there at the start where some of it was
still yellow and the rest of it was red
where the oxygen was coming into direct
contact with the liquid
okay
so when you dispose of it
you